ante la acusación de 34 delitos graves
el expresidente Donald Trump Se declaró
No culpable volvió de Nueva York a su
residencia de mar a lago en Florida
convocó a los medios de comunicación se
defendió y dijo que Estados Unidos es
una nación fallida criticó al presidente
Joe biden y aseguró que se enfrenta
interferencias electorales es el primer
presidente de Estados Unidos en ser
acusado
con este fiscal fracasado local acusando
a un expresidente de los Estados Unidos
por primera vez en la historia
basado en que cada
análisis dijo Es que no hay caso no hay
caso sigue diciéndolo pero no hay caso
El Criminal es el fiscal del distrito
porque
filtró un montón de información
privilegiada del Gran Jurado
[Aplausos]
Por lo cual Debería ser fiscalizada al
menos debería renunciar
la próxima audiencia será el 4 de
diciembre mientras los expertos
consideran que el juicio no comenzará
hasta dentro de un año además una
condena no impediría que Trump pudiera
postularse la presidencia la fiscalía le
acusa de orquestar pagos a dos mujeres
para ocultar que mantuvieron relaciones
sexuales con él antes de las elecciones
hoy mantenemos nuestra solemne
responsabilidad de garantizar que todos
sean iguales ante la ley ninguna
cantidad de dinero y ninguna cantidad de
poder cambie ese principio
estadounidense perdurable
Esta no es la única causa a la que
podría enfrentarse el expresidente
Donald Trump hay otras investigaciones
en curso por supuestamente intentar
anular los resultados de las elecciones
de 2020 y por el manejo de documentos
clasificados tras dejar su cargo